Rapoport had like a little get-together
for the fantasy football league how was
it it was I get a restaurant it was nice
he had a little section in the back
Wow and they brought some food and
drinks but it hardly anybody showed up
which i think was just me will Jason JD
did you shut up later on like lately
what do you were busy how's that a wine
tasting thing else look at him you
believe this [ __ ] where'd that set
you back
oh well that she got that was a birthday
present bird mean there it still comes
out of all your money it's your money
too
it's it's all your money I mean it's
it's all I might but yeah she used her
money she makes from her job thank you
for the wine dear you could do you guys
keep separate accounts for yes as of
right now yes yeah what is wine - you do
right now for - yeah we won it's uh I'm
not getting into the minutiae do you go
to your wife and you say honey rents due
this month I need your have I mean defer
tamale pay like the cable bill you're
telling me
[Laughter]
you guys don't have a joint bank account
not right now no I've talked about I'm
getting a the rent you've tried a check
for half of your amount and she writes
her check for half of it hardly her half
well I do it all and she sends a certain
amount she Vandross she writes you a
check
no she sends transfers money how can you
see her bank account like are you on the
same app or on the same with the same
bank where you can see both no it's too
different you don't know what she has uh
no but you know I have a general idea
when you were paying off all those
credit card bills did you guys do that
separately as well from separate so that
was all mainly me that was all me mm-hmm
she has her own credit cards yeah okay
good idea you don't know if she owes
money on him I know I does and she pays
let's say you go to a restaurant yes
and she goes 5050 with you well I mean
I'll pay mainly for the most part but
I'm sure we have chopper tracks how does
that work are you there with your wife
yeah the bill comes you throw in two
credit cards I'm sorry
is that right maybe she does Tim you had
two drinks I only had one like that is
it awkward when you have to put in
credit cards together
no I for the most part I do it because
no I don't fake you know significantly
more than her so what is what did what
does she pay for them uh she does
groceries and stuff like that she'll go
and foot the whole bill for the week has
she ever owed you money for something
that you had to like chase down you
better pray that morning I'm gonna be
relaxed welcome Jamie are you ultimately
the one who's responsible for paying the
bills like making sure the rent gets
paid the electricity gets paid yeah
because I deemed myself that person to
be responsible for Ronnie is there a
problem there what do you think of that
that's the way they do things this day
and age man it's weird
who's they eat 40 years old I'm telling
you people that's what I can tell you
what do you think is should he be doing
that I mean I
no man Steph aren't even married and she
has credit cards you know on my account
and right she wants to buy something she
buys it right you know and I pay for it
she but she does to food she does to
food and blows me in the bathroom
what about difficulty why not merge
accounts
it hasn't been anything I've thought was
a necessarily an issue is it a Power
Move like that she has to come to you
for money no no power move affect me all
me but Danny show me your tits it'll
rain money
[Laughter]